[Music]
what's up guys michael here to talk
about south park wait what was that
sure
sorry we're actually talking about war
the past few weeks the media has been
saturated with the latest upsetting
updates about russia's attack on ukraine
and because we have beating hearts the
whole situation has had us pretty
disturbed it's not that we're strangers
to hearing about armed conflict in the
news between civil wars long-term
violent unrest over territory and the
occasional undeclared american war that
lasts a goddamn lifetime it can start to
feel like state-sanctioned violence is
perpetual intractable and somewhat
ubiquitous but as we watch the most
surprising and depressing events of 2022
play out we've been wondering what is
the point of war why do human beings
always seem to be waging it is it
natural and yes of course what is it
good for absolutely
so join us on this very lighthearted
journey into the deeply violent depths
of mankind in this wisecrack edition on
war
why the answer to the question why war
might at first seem pretty obvious the
way most people explain humanity's
propensity for war is that it's
inevitable it's natural it just kind of
is
in fact if we had the production budget
to man on the street the question is war
natural we're pretty sure that one we'd
overwhelmingly hear yes and two i'd
probably get beaten up on hollywood
boulevard anyway that gut reaction has
some scientific and philosophical
credence most obviously there's the
classic philosophical screed from one
thomas hobbs who argued that life is
nasty brutish and short and he didn't
mean nasty in a good way or as the poet
nas once said
other proponents of this view that
violence amongst mankind just kind of
happens would include the likes of
william james and sigmund freud and
plenty of anthropological scholarship
bolsters this belief with fossilized
human bodies showing evidence of
man-on-man violence since the 1960s
anthropologists have used the savannah
baboon as a surrogate for early humans
and found that they appear to really
like hitting each other famously a study
of the yanamamo people one of the last
few remaining truly isolated
hunter-gatherer tribes conducted by
controversial anthropologist napoleon
chegnon found that men who committed
multiple murders had more reproductive
success i.e acquired more wives than
those who didn't he used these findings
to argue that violence is a desirable
evolutionary trait in male humans which
yeah that tracks with every james bond
movie i've seen however many scholars
push back on this idea altogether take
the yana mamo example for starters it's
been alleged that much of the violence
chagnon observed amongst the yanumamo
was actually caused by chagnon who
handed out machetes and axes to
encourage the tribe members to
participate in his study what's more
anthropologist douglas fry's analysis of
chagnon's data finds that the men who
committed murders were on average 10
full years older than the peaceful ones
giving them way more opportunity to you
know
land a few wives this is obviously an
isolated example but it speaks to a much
bigger epistemological problem that is a
problem with the way we acquire
knowledge according to frye western
scholars studying ancient
hunter-gatherer cultures tend to suffer
from a sort of confirmation bias because
we live in a world torn up by war where
violence is just part of the landscape
it's easy for folks studying ancient
humans to find evidence of war
everywhere skeletons of cavemen that
show damage to the skull for instance
are typically interpreted to be evidence
that one guy clubbed the other guy to
death thus humans are naturally violent
but fry argues that upon closer
inspection some cases like these have
been found to merely indicate that the
ancient human was attacked by animals or
that their skeleton had gone through
run-of-the-mill archaeological decay or
take the 9 000 year old walls of jericho
commonly thought of as the first
archaeological evidence of war which
have also caused some serious scholarly
disagreement some experts now believe
that the walls were built to protect the
city against flooding rather than
against hostile neighbors in his book
beyond war fry makes a compelling case
that for the majority of our existence
war is actually been extremely rare he
knows that although the violence of
homicide feud and war grab our attention
an examination of cross-cultural data
reveals that people usually deal with
conflicts without using any violence at
all while violence between individuals
usually male seems to have always been
around fry argues that the unmitigated
killing between two or more groups that
is necessary to constitute capital w war
is remarkably absent from most of human
history scholar john gowdy adds that
judging from historical accounts of
hunter-gatherers for most of the time
humans have been on the planet we have
lived in relative harmony with the
natural world and with each other our
minds and cultures evolved under these
conditions evidence suggests that war
emerged only when human social order
became more complex adopting among other
things hierarchies and horses what's
more large-scale war appears to have
only existed for less than 2 000 years a
mere drop in the bucket for homo sapiens
fry even argues that human beings have
successfully evolved precisely because
evolution favors restraint and limited
interpersonal aggression in fact it's
one of our strengths human beings are
creative and adaptive enough to find
non-violent solutions to problems such
as soliciting a friendly mediator
talking things out or my favorite tactic
simply running away from the angry guy
holding the club now the idea that human
beings are naturally prone towards peace
is of course contested but at the very
least fry's account throws a serious
shade of doubt on the assumption that
cavemen were prone to group violence and
that human beings are basically
chimpanzees with less facial hair and
many scholars agree with fry's
contention that most human societies
existed largely in a state of peace and
abundance you may be wondering why we're
talking about ancient hunter-gatherers
in our purported attempt to understand
modern war but it's really important
that we not take the reality of warfare
for granted that's because assuming that
humanity is naturally war happy
necessarily changes the way we react to
and think about war as fry explains
naturalizing war creates an unfortunate
self-fulfilling prophecy if war is
natural then there is little point in
trying to prevent reduce or abolish it
it's like the macro version of the
depressing statistic that people with a
gun in their house are more likely to
die of homicide and we'd argue that the
assumption that war amongst humans is
natural underpins a lot of the
narratives we tell ourselves about
ourselves these days it's easy to feel
like war is inevitable scholar james
hillman writes during the 5 600 years of
written history 14 600 wars have been
recorded two or three wars each year of
human history that's pretty staggering
but if you like us have a strong
distaste for organized human violence
it's worth looking to peaceful societies
no matter how differently they might be
structured from our own
what makes indiscriminate violence
between two or more groups of people so
rare until relatively recently arguably
the lack of fixed group identity plays a
pretty big role see in ancient
hunter-gatherer societies if you belong
to one band of people and gotten a big
fight with your bunkmate you would often
simply leave that band and join a
different one and because lineage was
frequently tracked both matrilineally
and patriarchally you would have kin in
multiple tribes so you had friendly
options what's more the overlapping
fluxus state of group membership made
violence between groups less likely
overall as fry explains about the
aboriginal people of australia banned
membership was neither closed nor static
individuals and families shifted banned
residents over both the short term and
the long term virtually every person had
relatives and contacts in other groups
these overlapping social and kinship
networks that spanned the flexible bands
served to damp intergroup hostility the
idea of floating between a network of
groups at first blush might be hard for
us to relate to most of us forge our
identity largely based on the groups we
permanently belong to like
bald dudes with hearts of gold and
slightly raised cholesterol and often we
identify primarily by our country of
origin a scholar benedict anderson wrote
back in 1983 nation-ness is the most
universally legitimate value in the
political life of our time but it's
important to note that the idea of
national identity is a relatively new
one if you take the grand span of human
history into account some scholars note
that while some medieval elites may have
had a national consciousness thanks in
part to the influence of the church this
didn't really reach the masses and
become modern nationalism until the 18th
century when thanks to enlightenment and
romantic thinking nationalism became
what scholar john hutchinson calls a
surrogate religion whereas previously
borders have been porous the concept of
the unified nation carried a greater
sense of solidarity when it emerged in
europe around this time anderson
attributes the rise of european
nationalism in the late 1700s to three
things first the fall of latin as
europe's universal religious language
accompanied by the rise of national
dialects second the death of the divine
monarch in the cultural imagination
which required now precariously
positioned rulers to seek out other
forms of legitimacy and lastly the
emergence of the mass-produced newspaper
which united countrymen and a shared
experience and worldview these factors
coalesced to start building more robust
national identities now of course there
was war before there were modern nations
ancient empires didn't form out of pure
fondness for their leaders and there
were outliers of large-scale long-term
warfare long before the 18th century
such as the hundred years war which
ended in 1453. see england and france
used it to figure out uh
who gets to own and be france obviously
a young chicago woman named emily cooper
who is in paris because we're talking
about emily in paris but if anything
this was a precursor of things to come
the people involved were starting to be
attuned to large collective identities
that would solidify and strengthen in
future centuries anderson refers to a
nation as an imagined political
community because a person in any given
country could never possibly know all of
their fellow community members creating
a nation anderson explains also forges a
deep horizontal comradeship that is
shared amongst its people but according
to him this sense of camaraderie is not
without potential consequence he
contends that ultimately it is this
fraternity that makes it possible over
the past two centuries for so many
millions of people not so much to kill
as willingly to die for such limited
imaginings that is perhaps to say that
without our deep national allegiances it
wouldn't be possible to convince so many
people to go to war in the first place
to be clear anderson's views are not
unopposed and some scholars think the
connection between nationalism and war
can be overstated but interestingly
enough others argue that there's also a
reciprocal relationship between war and
nationalism scholar john hutchinson
argues that wars in their aftermath only
further bolster national identities
that is to say our nations might bring
us to war but war also brings us closer
to our nations or as scholar charles
tilley says war made the state and the
state made war now obviously there's
nothing wrong with being proud of your
country of origin or with having your
identity deeply tied to it but fry's
research does substantiate anderson's
argument he found pretty conclusively
that as society trended away from loose
hierarchy-free collectives and towards
governed organized nation-states war
became far more likely across the board
that's not exactly surprising you can't
assemble an army out of a small band of
loosely connected people but you can
destroy the one ring to rule them all
militarism necessarily relies on butt
loads of folks willing to risk their
lives for something bigger and that
something is very often a nation and
that deeply ingrained sense of national
pride facilitates the kinds of wars our
ancient ancestors never would have
thought to wage in the first place of
course you need more than just a complex
society to wage a war and not all
complex societies do fry determined back
in 2006 that 20 countries in recent
history have gone at least a hundred
years without a war you need one more
all-important thing and it's not a
literal enemy as hillman writes in his
book a terrible love of war all along we
are speaking of the idea of an enemy a
phantom enemy it is not the enemy that
is essential to war and that forces war
upon us but the imagination imagination
is the driving force the way we imagine
our enemies then rather than any
reality-based rage or hatred is often
the true instigator of war we don't talk
a lot about the nature of war today
which eschews the organized battlefields
of say the civil war where reporters
could safely observe from the sidelines
for targeted airstrikes that typically
dig into civilian territory and
specifically we don't often discuss how
war is actually more dangerous for
regular folks than ever before as
reporter carolyn nordstrom notes
approximately 90 of casualties in modern
warfare are civilians the enemy is no
longer enlisted soldiers fulfilling
duties in the trenches as we've seen all
too glaringly in the coverage of ukraine
as well as in decades of american
airstrikes in the middle east just to
name a few today it's hard to imagine a
war that doesn't involve civilian
casualties and this can feel pretty
depressing when you're someone with
functionally no control over geopolitics
fry is ever the optimist he notes that
humans have survived for so long
precisely because we're highly inventive
and adaptive after all we largely went
from living in tiny bands of foragers to
industrialized cities in the
evolutionary blink of an eye and he
argues that with enough political will
we could use that adaptiveness to
construct a world without wars and while
that may sound a bit sentimental we
thought we owed you at least one
uplifting thought so what do you guys
think is war just the inevitable result
of modern civilization would we be
better off if society had never come up
with alternatives to hunting and
gathering let us know in the comments
huge thanks to our patrons for all your
support be sure to check out our new
patreon page or drop in some new
exclusive content tap that subscribe
button gently like the peaceful homo
sapien you are and don't forget to ring
that bell and as always thanks for
watching later
[Music]
you